le premier festival international de la
mode s'ouvre ce soir à paris pour trois
jours
ne pas confondre avec le salon chaque
pays a le sien ici dans festival des
créateurs et des industriels du monde
entier vont se retrouver emilie raffoux
et derrière les branches et les
classiques les sportswear et autres baba
derrière cette vitrine de look se trouve
une industrie colossal la seconde
industrie française après l'armement le
prêt-à-porter
des chiffres impressionnants dix-sept
mineurs et demi de chiffre d'affaires
une exportation en hausse de 25% par
rapport à 1983
dix sept mille employés un excédent
commercial de 2 milliards et demi bref
une industrie florissante et pourtant si
les professionnels de la mode se
réunissent c'est que malte où il ya des
faux prix et des coûts sur mal fait
celle par exemple entre les créateurs et
les industriels un alliage difficile
avec des besoins plutôt divergents
ils sont rares à avoir réussi les deux
jeux sont probablement parmi les seuls
qui ont à la fois contrôler la création
et le marketing etc en fait
ces sables et le marquis ne sais quoi
c'est avant tout un bon sens paysan qui
veut dire que nous sommes créatifs et
que nous avons un bon sens paysan ses
côtés création certains se penche déjà
sur les années 90 la compétition se fait
de plus en plus féroce avec les japonais
les italiens ou les anglais alors pour
rester la capitale de la mode comme le
revendiquent les professionnels il faut
encore et toujours innover voilà ce
qu'on nous propose pour les années à
venir
confort la journée sophistication la
nuit le problème aujourd'hui c'est que
chaque l'une ans et plus qu'à sa tête
il n'y a plus une mode mais mille mode
s'il fallait rêver un peu l'idéal ce
serait de pouvoir habiller chaque femme
pour qu'elle soit la plus belle et
qu'elle se réalise le mieux selon ses
rêves de quoi habiller à la puissance
mille pour satisfaire tout le monde
un langage qui ne devrait certainement
pas déplaire aux industriels